[Music]
almost everyone can still remember the
messed up conception of sonic's
appearance and the resulting outrage
what followed was an elaborate
post-production and commercially
successful sonic the hedgehog movie
of course the announcement of a
successor didn't take long and as it
looks now
the production will start soon at least
that's what many relevant websites with
reference to the bc creative film
commission report
as the entry with the name emerald hill
appeared on the website of the company
responsible for the shooting a clear
hint actually because emerald hill zone
is also the name of a level in the
second sonic video game from 1992. the
entry
also refers to the period from march to
may 2021 which would make the expected
release date on april 8
2022 quite realistic in any case we are
curious and we'll keep you informed
as usual on thursday walnut brothers
officially announced that all films to
be released next year will be available
at the cinema
and on hbo max simultaneously the
decision will be applied beginning next
year and is not intended to extend
beyond 2021
after it was already clear that wonder
woman 1984 would be released based on
this model
a whole series of top class blockbusters
are now following
these include the suicide squad dune
tom and jerry godzilla vs kong and
many more a new aspect is the fact that
the different films will be released on
hbo
max and in cinemas on the same day which
of course will not be very popular among
cinema owners
the reactions of the fans have so far
been consistently positive
many even expect one of the smartest
business moves in the history of
filmmaking
because netflix and others can't compete
with all the exclusive and top class
films
of course all viewers outside of the usa
are more or less missing out
because the subscription to hbo max is
so far only available in the usa
but it is of course likely that this
will change soon after this big move
what do you think pretty clever move for
the final destruction of cinemas as we
know it
with hawkeye the next big disney plus
series is on its way
what's been driving fans for a year is
the question of who will replace the
marvel hero as hawkeye in the course of
the series
some sources reported bumblebee star
hailey steinfeld as kate bishop
but this was never confirmed as a first
video of shooting in a new york subway
station shows
many were riding their assumption
because in fact not only jeremy renner
but also haley steinfeld can be seen
here
you can also see her holding a bow in
one hand and a dog leash in the other
actually this can only be lucky the
pizza dog who is a sidekick in the
marvel comics
jeremy renner also celebrates the
beginning of the shooting with a picture
of a chair with the name of his main
character
clint barton at the moment many are
expecting a disney plus release in late
2021 or early 2022
but an official date has not yet been
set
besides hawkeye marvel fans can also
look forward to one division in
mid-january and
loki and the falcon and the winter
soldier in the near future
after the 2003 daredevil movie with ben
affleck as matt murdock was big flop
it was quite around the marvel character
for a long time
only the mostly positive rated netflix
series with charlie cox's daredevil
gained popularity among the fans after a
while
and was cancelled in 2018 after three
seasons
on november 29th exactly two years later
netflix film rights finally expired
which means that the story around myrtle
could finally be used in some way for
the mcu
of course this wasn't overlooked by the
fans and so a fan campaign was started
under the hashtag
safe daredevil with a goal to keep the
same cast and age restriction
more or less the complete netflix series
running on marvel
how disney or marvel will respond to
this and how daredevil could be
integrated into the universe is not
known at this time
how do you feel about that do you want
to see the superheroes soon on marvel as
well or have the three seasons on
netflix already been enough for you
feel free to write it in the comments
a few days ago it was announced that
emma stone is no longer considered for
damien chazelle's hollywood epic
babylon this comes as a bit of a
surprise as chazelle's collaboration
with stone has earned the 32 year old in
oscar as best actress in 2017
the reason for the exit however is not
supposed to be dispute between the two
but rather stone's busy schedule
the suitable replacement also seems to
have been found because as the rep
reports
the la la land actress will be replaced
by none other than magorobi
not much is known about the content yet
but one suspects a historical drama
which is supposed to take place in the
1920s or
30s the film industry and the
revolutionary change from silent to
sound film will be the focus of
attention
we can expect an official release as
early as february 17
2022 but in view of the fact that
shooting has not yet begun
we dare to doubt that so far
all that was known was that james 1 is
working on a project for universal's
monster franchise
but now it is clear which one a van
helsing movie
many people will know the vampire hunter
of the same name especially through hugh
jackman's not quite so convincing
performance in 2004
even if the main actor has not yet been
determined at least one director has
been found for the blockbuster
namely julius avery who became known to
a wider audience mainly through
operation overlord so it seems
reasonable to assume that van helsing by
julius avery will be
anything but tame after all james wan a
master of the horror genre is also on
board as producer
nothing is known about the content yet
but it will be exciting to see
which direction the film develops at the
latest after universal's expensive flop
the mummy with tom cruise they could go
for small but
nice blockbusters without any big
gimmicks in the future in addition to
van helsing
other similar films such as the wolfman
bride of frankenstein
renfield and dracula are also in
production at universal a release date
for vendor housing is unfortunately
not yet fixed
[Music]
bye